so i have a few
questions i ask everybody during the
pandemic i'm just going to start with
those
uh what tv series would each of you love
to guest star on
nurse jackie i mean succession really
well you can
it's been an obvious choice but nurse
jackie wow i love that
uh what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
center stage i think my sister can
i have her to blame that she had um an
obsession with the sound of music which
was on
the whole [ __ ] time in my house so i
think probably that was like
like a constant um there it is that was
not out of choice i have to say
well you stayed and watched it i mean it
was there it went on i could not yeah
he could have hit it upstairs you know
next question
i can see the way it was on set uh james
individual question for you
um you went to school in cambridge and
i've been to that city
and it's like transporting back in time
i'm just curious what it was like to go
to school there
i mean i had an amazing magical three
years they work you hard
that's not a myth they they really do
kind of squeeze it all in but um
yeah it's very special i remember being
very very tired at the end one of the
terms of
you know doing my exams and i bumped
into a guy and i was like stressing out
and he goes
dude like you're in the most beautiful
city in the world reading the books you
want to read
in some of the most beautiful libraries
in the world getting taught by some of
the most impressive people in the world
so just
calm down it was a real kind of it was a
real moment yeah i am kind of lucky it
was special very special
yes amanda if you've never been to
cambridge in england i strongly
recommend
i've been to oxford isn't that the same
thing
no okay it's not i mean it's same in
ish but the cities are very different
and um cambridge is more kind of
uh concentrated in the middle and more
beautiful
yeah and there's amazing history in that
city um so
for both of you jumping into the movie
uh i am curious how long
it took to talk to karen about indiana
jones
when she showed up on set karen and i
all we talked about
was knitting and
we also share uh like best friends
james did you talk to her about indiana
jones because i didn't
we did talk to her about her work very
briefly at the very beginning
and then we moved on very quickly but
she agreed to
yeah no we did we did we found that what
if people are like
that again yeah all right so you know
what i mean i don't want to step on the
wrong
you know wrong foot right at the
beginning is that no she was fine
she was she was very lovely she also had
like a very
old like x on set which is quite
interesting so so she turned up well
yeah it was a it was one of her like
previous
flames i hope she doesn't mind us saying
that she might she and michael had
had once been an item so that that's a
couple quite a lot of conversation
wow that actually could be awkward
and it wasn't they were like they were
lovely
uh for each of you i'm assuming
listen what was it about the script and
story that said i really want to do this
oh upstate like washington irving
territory i mean it's just the most
beautiful place on earth
i live there so it's like to tell a
story
around halloween about an incredibly
haunted marriage an
incredibly haunted house in a haunted
town with like
this this around like mother nature
takes over it's just
it couldn't have been any any better you
know
i just wanted to work with amanda
obviously that was one yeah
bob and sherry obviously no i uh yeah i
mean they had the role for me the
character and the marriage particularly
yeah the um the dysfunctionality of that
of that dynamic um was really enticing
and it kind of
exciting to to mine and amanda we we'd
have a lot of fun
we had a lot of fun kind of playing the
most dysfunctional family yeah it's a
good role it's a meaty role and it he
definitely goes on a pretty
pretty mad journey without giving
anything away one of the things that i
enjoyed while i was watching is that as
you watch the movie
layers are being pulled back and you're
starting to figure things out
before you got the script how much did
you find out about the actual story
and how much are people saying you read
the script let me know what you think
right i was given the script blank yeah
you
mean how much information do you have
before you read yeah like i'm curious
like
do your agents tell you like here's the
arc or they like read the script let us
know what you think
sometimes they do but generally you want
to try i think
i i prefer it i generally prefer if they
give you the
the experience of discovery like you
said where they give it to you and they
say i really liked this
and if they say i really i really hated
this you're like okay i guess i won't
read it you
like sometimes our careers are in the
agents yeah they're living there yet
take a big responsibility for sure but
yeah i think i think um
i mean yeah it depends if you can be if
some people probably don't read
everything don't
you know so yeah my my age is definitely
uh tell me if they like it and then give
me the experience of
unpicking and unpeeling as you said uh i
heard that that when you guys were
filming i don't know if this is true
that there were weird noises in the
house and that the walls had been filled
with bees
and like honey at one point it was like
dripping out like
is this true and what was it like what
was it like to work in this house
there were bees i remember that you just
didn't want to get stung you know
it was like a minefield and it made it
all more exciting
it was kind of creepy there was this
there was this atmosphere it was this
derelict house i think it was in between
sails in the middle of nowhere
surrounded by trees and an old milk
dairy farm and it was kind of
it was it was we obviously projected a
lot into it because we were shooting a
horror movie but
um yeah it was fun we definitely heard a
few creeks and
cracks and then one of the ads stayed
overnight there and we all thought he
was really brave
on that note i got to stop congrats on
the movie uh i hope you guys enjoy the
rest of your speed dating today